il est vrai que les relations union
cathares on en parle beaucoup
actuellement du fait de la Coupe du
monde mais c'est pas un partenaire
économique sur lequel on table on voit
bien les discussions sur les accords de
commerce ils sont pas focalisés sur de
tels pays même si on a conclu des
accords sur les questions aériennes avec
le Qatar parce que c'est un gros hub
aérien le président du Conseil européen
Charles Michel s'est rendu dernièrement
en Quatar pour ouvrir une délégation de
l'Union européenne dans ce pays parce
qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit dans
votre reportage et dans votre
introduction c'est vraiment les
relations du fait du contexte sur la
question du gaz notamment qu'on souhaite
développer pour diversifier nos sources
d'approvisionnement je partage ce que
dit Jean Quatremer on le voit bien on a
des dépendances critiques à l'égard de
certains partenaires et on retombe dans
la même logique et il faut pas être naïf
le Qatar a une stratégie très claire
vis-à-vis justement du soft power à
travers le sport ça a été dit avec le
PSG c'est c'est très flagrant sur le
football mais c'est pas que sur le
football c'est sur l'automobile
sur l'histoire etc donc il y a une vraie
stratégie justement de d'avoir une image
positive quand tous les cathares posent
avec la Tour Eiffel derrière c'est
justement cette question de ce de ce
faire une belle image sur la scène
internationale et donc nous on voit que
justement on augmente notre dépendance
et c'est ça le risque donc je reviens
aussi sur la question j'entends ce que
dit mon collègue Tarabella sur les
droits des travailleurs les évolutions
positives mais quoi je regardais moi
aussi en préparant le nombre de morts
c'est deux fois ma ville quoi c'est
quand même aberrant pour conduire
près de 6700 oui je vis dans une petite
ville mais quand même deux fois ma ville
mais et on voit en plus que maintenant
le Qatar se refuse sur les droits
compensation des victimes alors la
Fédération française de football a
annoncé qu'elle elle veut participer à
un fonds de compensation mais quand même
ça ça doit nous interpeller
l'organisation d'une coupe du monde
comme ça ça participe à un processus
sur ce que dit mon collègue je partage
en partie mais c'est là aussi où l'Union
européenne elle-même à sa propre
responsabilité on a actuellement les
travaux sur le devoir de vigilance là
aussi il faudra qu'on ait un texte
véritablement ambitieux qui justement
travaille sur l'entièreté de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement de valeur pour
permettre d'augmenter les droits des
travailleurs bien sûr en Europe mais à
l'extérieur de l'Union européenne donc
c'est vrai que je partage le fait de
dire ne soyons pas démoralisateurs mais
faisons aussi nous-mêmes notre travail
de législateur il y a un accord qui a
été conclu signé aérien avec avec le
Qatar ce qui permet entre l'Union
européenne et le Qatar ce qui crée un
espace un ciel ouvert entre le Qatar et
l'Europe ce qui fait que Qatar Airways
peut se comporter en Europe comme
n'importe quel autre compagnie aérienne
pour les Européens d'avoir accès en
Europe il y a 450 millions d'Européens
et de consommateurs au Qatar il y en a 3
millions et a priori il y a pas
énormément de compagnies aériennes que
ça intéresse de profiter du hub de DOA
donc pourquoi est-ce que signe ça
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait ça là aussi
je pense que c'est une part un peu de
naïveté de l'Union européenne de signer
de tels accords il y a eu à l'époque
aussi notamment dans les compagnies
aériennes européennes et françaises
beaucoup de grève au moment de cette
ratification parce que justement il
dénonçait le fait qu'il y allait avoir
encore plus de concurrence déloyale pour
les travailleurs dans ces différentes
compagnies donc c'est vrai qu'on
enseigne de plus en plus mais là encore
il faut être très vigilant dans le
rapproche mais parce que représente
aussi un hub essentiel pour avoir accès
à l'Asie pour là aussi c'est que le
Qatar a fait ça
dans l'exemple qui est cité justement là
et avec l'unflation réduction actes des
Américains lu la France est très vocale
sur ce sujet notamment Bruno Le Maire
mais on entend pas cette vidéo européen
personne parle français
un peu plus on parle un peu plus
français à Bruxelles mais quand même on
voit les on voit les limites mais là
aussi nous on dit que justement parce
que c'est contraire aux règles de l'OMC
il faudra attaquer un si nécessaire à
l'ouest oui déjà alors le temps mais qui
déjà est-ce que la présidente voudra
rien que le faire alors que nous sommes
en droit et nous avons le devoir de le
faire et ça ça
vient de dire mon collègue effectivement
maintenant il faut travailler les
conditions de la paix mais ça on le voit
bien ça sera quand même très difficile
et ça sera très difficile aussi sur le
long terme de le garantir mais c'est
notre là aussi notre devoir et notre
responsabilité et si je rebondis par
rapport à l'éditorial je pense qu'on
voit aussi que le rôle de la Banque
centrale tel qu'on l'a conçu à une
époque plus nécessairement là aussi
adapté donc c'est à nous aussi en tant
que parlementaire de revoir comment on
peut travailler à l'évolution des rôles
de la Banque centrale européenne ça veut
dire quoi parce que la banque centrale
sont rôles en gros c'est d'éviter
l'inflation au-delà de 2 % là je pense
que on y est donc ça peut être quoi
d'autre bah après c'est
effectivement il faut travailler